DR. PETER MAGNUSSON: All
right, good day.
So shalom, I'm Peter
Magnusson.
I was trying to practice the
phrase "how are you guys" in
Hebrew, but it didn't stick.
MALE SPEAKER: Come on!
You trained on it.
DR. PETER MAGNUSSON:
I was training over
there, but it didn't--
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING HEBREW].
DR. PETER MAGNUSSON:
[REPEATING HEBREW].
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
DR. PETER MAGNUSSON: So
pleasure to be here.
So I'm Peter Magnusson.
I'm an engineering director
at Google.
Most of my work is I run App
Engine engineering and also
run much of the business side
of App Engine, and I'm also
involved in some other areas
of Cloud Platform.
I'll have my email at
the end as well.
But if you're App Engine
developers and you hate
something, then email
that, and I'll tell
someone else to fix it.
So what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to go over just--
for those of you who don't know,
this presentation has
like two sections that
I'm going to go
through pretty quick.
And we're around afterwards for
conversations and so forth.
So I'm going to have the first
couple of slides, just for
those of you who don't know
what App Engine is at all,
just present a little bit more
in detail about what it is.
And then I have another section
that sort of assumes
you are actually an App Engine
developer, and you care about
some details.
And I'm going to go through
some of the roadmap stuff.
And hopefully there's a couple
of new items in there.
If you've been super paying
attention online and so forth,
not much of this will be new.
So the original vision from App
Engine was to be able to
make it really simple to write
apps and make it really easy
for them to do manage them for
scalability and for management
of them and ownership of them.
So the sort of mantra that we
derived was that it should be
very easy to build.
It should be simple to scale.
It's never, ever trivial
to scale.
No matter how easy, you
sort of set it up.
But it really should be
trivial to manage.
We changed prices about
a year and a half ago.
And I got a fun email from a
user who got really upset that
he suddenly had to enable his
credit card because the
application-- he hadn't had to
do anything on his application
for six months.
And then a few minutes
afterwards, he sent me another
email, and he just realized when
he typed that, that the
fact that he hadn't had to
do anything to keep the
application running for six
months maybe meant it was
worth $3 a month.
So it's a platform.
You build and test your app.
You upload it, and everything
else is managed by Google.
Nowadays this is referred to
as platform as a service.
The creation of App Engine was
actually one of the products
that instigated people to invent
the term "platform as a
service" because the idea really
is to make it invisible
to you what the facilities are
that it's running on-- to hide
that it's VM, to hide that
there's discs, to hide that
there's network--
and focus on the developer
experience.
Ideally you should just be given
a straight as forward as
possible API definition, and
then be able to write the
application, and then just
worry about the business
logic, and then be able to
manage it from web pages.
And then you should have as
little as possible else to
worry about.
If you're interested in finding
out a little bit
better, we recently launched
something called Cloud
Playground, which allows you
edit simple App Engine
applications on your web
browser and run them.
It's actually an App Engine
application that creates App
Engine applications and then
manages them and runs them.
Pretty cool, sort of
self-referential, and we're
going to be increasingly using
this as sort of live
documentation so that when
there are sample code and
things, how to do things, you
can just click on it, and it
actually creates an application
for you.
You don't have to install an
SDK or anything like that.
In the interest of time, I'm not
going to demo this today.
Of course, just a quick flash
that, increasingly, the Cloud
Platform is a mixture of
a number of different
capabilities.
So as applications become
more complicated, more
sophisticated, you start
bringing in more assets of
what Google has across
Cloud Platform.
Notable is the addition of
Compute Engine, which
initially is being used a lot
for batch processing and
things like that.
And a number of related
services around it--
messaging, endpoints--
I'll be talking about
a few of them.
But the idea to--
the vision is to allow you to
approach Cloud Platform in one
of two ways.
You can either come at it
with a greenfield idea.
You're writing something from
scratch, and then you get
started on App Engine,
just off you go.
And then as it becomes more
complicated or needs some more
specific capabilities, you can
expand out to use other Cloud
Platform products.
Or you are forklifting over from
another more traditional
LAMP stack.
And we're moving towards making
it easier for you
on-board existing stacks
and existing
setups onto Cloud Platform.
Let's see here.
So here's a fun example of
a happy startup customer.
In the US, there is a lot of
startup activity around shared
writing, new forms of Taxi from
all different kinds of
perspectives.
It's quite interesting,
actually.
One of them is a company called
Getaround, which aims
to make it really simple for
you to rent your car to
somebody else.
And they won a TechCrunch
Disrupt, which is in the US a
pretty distinguished
way of getting
out there as a startup.
And the traffic curve here
is what happened when the
announcement came out
that they'd won.
And it came out on Twitter
because everybody was
following TechCrunch.
So they went up, I think,
something like two orders of
magnitude in traffic in the
immediate interest.
And all their operations
engineers are visible in this
picture because they were all
up on stage accepting the
prize while this thing
is going off.
And they realized afterwards
that none of
their pagers went off.
Nobody was calling
and complaining.
It just sort of just worked.
And they came back, and they
looked at this chart, and they
emailed it over to us, and
they said, thanks, guys.
It just worked.
Now I do encourage you to
benchmark that if you haven't
gotten any broken logic in your
software when it hits
that spike because we can't
fix your source for you.
Another sort of bigger--
Greg already mentioned SongPop
as one example.
But I wanted to emphasize some
of the numbers here.
This is a startup that went from
0 to 60 million users in
less than a year without having
to re-architect or
rebuild or anything like that.
And they did this
was a shockingly
small number of engineers.
And we're striving increasingly
to make it easier
to maintain, have visibility
into what's going on, adding
various ways for analyzing your
code, and see where your
costs are going.
So that's sort of what
App Engine is.
So the next couple of slides
are going to--
if you don't know much about App
Engine, you can check your
cell phones or look out the
window or something.
I'm going to go into more
details for those if you
really care about App Engine.
So I'm going to be summarizing
some of the new things that
we're doing and that we're
adding and some of the themes
of improvements.
There's a lot of investment
that we're doing
improving App Engine.
So an application today in App
Engine is basically one or
more versions of one
a more instances.
And one of the nice things about
App Engine is how easy
it is to manage versions and
roll back versions and run
multiple versions without having
to think about how
that's actually done
on the system.
And the principal data system,
storage system that's used out
of the box that's really easy
to use, is the Datastore.
And then as you start getting
bigger, you want to start
using the Memcache, and then you
want to start building a
modularized application where
you're splitting out different
kinds of logic from front-end
serving traffic to analysis
and business logic.
I know you're probably
orchestrating this with
something called Task Queues.
You're probably starting to use
some of the other storages
like BLOB storage.
And increasingly, if the
application become
sophisticated, you start
writing multi-language.
For example, it's quite common
for people to write the
front-end code in Python because
it's very easy to
prototype and iterate and the
backend server kind of code
either in Java or GO because
they tend to be more
appropriate for code that's not
undergoing so much change.
In fact, I advocate people
to do all prototype
development in Python.
And then when they're going to
do a recode and cleanup to
rebuild it in Java.
And then you will also tend to
start breaking it up into
multiple applications, some
handling the mobile version,
some handling some
backend stuff.
So as your applications get more
sophisticated and as our
customers get more, demanding we
sort of identified a number
of areas to improve things.
Most of these we announced at
I/O. Some of them are already
out, and some of them we're in
the middle of rolling out.
First of all, the Memcache that
was available for App
Engine developers was
a shared Memcache.
It wasn't just shared with other
App Engine developers.
It was assets that were shared
with other Google resources.
The benefit of that was
that it was free.
So we're going to keep that
option, so there is a free
Memcache for App Engine
developers.
But we then discovered lots of
customers who said, look, we
don't really care if
it costs or not.
We actually just want it to
behave a lot better for us,
and we need a lot more-- we had
customers telling us they
wanted 2 terabytes
of Memcache.
So we've added a--
it's now in preview--
dedicated Memcache.
You can make your own
reservations.
You're in control of it.
There's no evictions from
other applications.
You just dial up how much you
need for your application.
This has been extremely popular
with the larger customers.
Task Queues has had a number
of challenges If you have a
user of them.
It's been used in ways
that it wasn't really
intended to be used.
People started using it as
effectively a message bus.
with massive rights.
It was kind of intended as sort
of like a cron job thing.
Things you can't do in 30 or
60-second response time, you
would throw it off to there.
Some developers are using it as
a fan in for the data store
and other like completely
crazy use cases.
And it wasn't really built for
50,000 queries per second.
Again, it's a task
queue system.
But we sort of realized that
we should adapt to the
patterns because we're
assuming mostly that
developers aren't idiots.
They're actually trying to do
patterns that makes sense.
In some cases the developers
are idiots, but most of the
time they're not.
So we're doing a lot of
re-engineering of Task Queues
to address a lot of the
responsiveness--
stability capabilities,
improving
statistics, and so forth.
So if you've been having
problems with Task Queues the
last few quarters, expect this
to be improving a lot over the
next months as we
roll this out.
Another big thing which we
recently started rolling out
this is what we call
App Engine modules.
And it's basically another--
we used to have the abstraction
of applications
and versions.
And now we've also added the
abstraction of modules, so you
can build modularized
applications with different
settings and so forth.
We've had some customers cut
their cost with App Engine by
30 or 40% because they can we
architect their application so
that they're don't have to force
front-end traffic and
backend requests into the same
logic, and they can set the
latencies differently.
So one way of exemplifying
that is if you have a
front-end service, you want
to have very, very good
guarantees of low latencies, but
they take very small time
to service.
Then you want to have
a certain scheduler
settings for that.
But if you have more like
backend queries, backend
processing, you can probably
accept seconds of latencies
for response times so then you
don't have to have big compute
assets up available at the
time, which leads to much
higher efficiencies.
We're also improving the
integration with cloud storage
for migrating, in fact, from old
BLOB store to just Google
Cloud Storage and adding default
storage bucket support
and making it much easier to be
managing and adding buckets.
So in general, App Engine will
increasingly become--
for those of you who have
applications that are
basically storage management
applications of various
flavors, App Engine will become
a very, very good
platform for adding the layer
of logic on top of that.
Yes, and of course, cloud
storage, per se, has more
features than the BLOB store.
Skip that.
Probably the biggest thing that
we're doing in the second
half of 2013 is we
are rolling out
something called VM Runtime.
The Trusted Tester Program for
this is available, so if you
want to sign up and start
playing with it, you can find
it on our forums.
We did sort of a pretty low-key
announcement of this
thing on the forums.
But it's a pretty big deal
because we don't need that may
testers for it, and we didn't
want to get people too excited
because we need to stabilize
this for a bit.
But basically, it is Compute
Engine VMs presented in an App
Engine environment.
And I do have a great demo for
it, but in the interest of
time, I won't run it.
But basically we're creating a
container that runs on a VM
that is a Compute Engine VM.
So it's a full-fledged VM that
is fully forward compatible
from App Engine, so your App
Engine code will run
unmodified on a VM.
And as a developer, the only
thing you do is change one
line of configuration.
You have to tell App Engine that
this is not running on a
Python App Engine front end.
It's running on a full VM.
And then App Engine will
just do everything
that needs to be done.
You don't have to worry about
load balancing for it, or
[? odd ?] scaling, or failover,
or health checking,
or any of that.
It just magically brings up
a VM in the background
that runs that code.
So this sort of begins the
process of muddying the waters
of what is the difference
between infrastructure as a
service and platform
as a service.
Because as we start adding
infrastructure capabilities to
platform as a service, like
Cloud Storage and Compute, and
as we're adding improved
platform management and
infrastructure management
capabilities to Compute
Engine, which is our
infrastructure as a service,
it becomes a continuum.
So one of things we're striving
to do is instead of
having this cliff difference
between, OK, you either are
fully managed or you are in
charge of all the bits and
bolts is to create a continuum
where you can let us manage
things for you unless you have
very particular opinions about
parts of it, and then
you go in the sort
of manage it yourself.
Greg mentioned one of the
analogies that we use here to
explain what we're trying to do,
which is in the old days,
you would write a Pascal
program, but it wasn't really
good at numerical code.
So then you'd throw in some
assembly language when you
needed it, but only once you
discovered that you needed it.
And we think the new world of
cloud computing is going to
have the analogous of very
powerful high-level
abstractions for building
applications, but where you
can sort of opt out of
it in areas that it
makes a lot of sense.
To make this complete, let
me give you an example.
We had one customer who was
pretty unhappy with how much
it cost them to use Datastore
for a presence server.
If you're not familiar with
what a presence server is,
basically a lot of social
applications and so forth need
a service that you can easily
query and say, which of my
friends are online right now
in some sense of online?
And they ended up using
Datastore for this.
They would push the time stamps
into it and do queries,
which is a pretty insane use of
Datastore, because that is
a massively backed-up,
replicated, multidata center,
yada, yada, yada.
And I asked them, do you really
need multiple lines on
this thing?
Isn't the reality of that if
this server goes down every
couple days or five minutes,
it doesn't really matter,
because this is not critical?
And they said, yeah, yeah,
that's not important at all.
So I said, well, if you just do
a single stand-up server on
this and just restart it every
two days and just have it all
in cache, that's like one or two
orders of magnitudes less
expensive resource-wise than
running a massive data
system behind it.
But the reality is, in the
past, those kind of
architectural decisions were
really, really cumbersome to
do in App Engine.
Historically, you'd see two.
You would have to hop out to
Compute Engine now and then do
all the logic to tie everything
together yourself.
What we're trying to do here is
that if you discover that
there's a section of your code
that really would be useful to
break out a service, specialized
service,
specialized storage thing, and
you want to code that up in
C++ or whatever.
We want to make it really,
really simple for you to say,
oh, I just need four
servers over here.
And here's the 4,000 lines of
C++, and just give me 128 gig
of memory, and then we start
the servers every week, and
I'm fine, without having to do
any configuration other than
what I just said.
So that's what we're targeting
here, and we think this is
going to be a really big deal.
And then, of course, PHP has
been the biggest request over
a long period of time.
It turns out that an
embarrassing percentage of the
internet is written in PHP.
So PHP is like the new x86 that
very few people defend on
aesthetic grounds.
But it's the reality
it's the assembly
language of the internet.
So we've added PHP support.
And when we add PHP support to
App Engine, it's just like a
LAMP stack with PHP on it.
We've actually ported the 5.4
XenServer to run on App Engine
NaCl server side.
So you have a dramatically
different experience.
This is not your typical
PHP server.
This is scaling much more
quickly, better security.
It again has the characteristic
that if you're
not getting traffic for
it, it goes down
zero cost in serving.
So this has been greeted
with a lot of interest.
Yeah, I think I covered a lot of
this, and Greg covered the
Cloud Datastore.
And as we're coordinating
between App Engine And Compute
Engine, we'll be adding cloud
deployment services to make it
easier for you pushing
out systems that cut
across these services.
Let's see, I'm probably
totally out
of time, so I should--
how's the--
I'm OK?
11:10 was my cutoff, right?
Oh wow!
Ha, ha!
Look at that, look at that.
So another thing that's pretty
cool if you're a mobile
developer or mobile is
important for your
application, which
I would assume is
true for many of you.
It's more than half of--
in fact, we're seeing the bulk
of development happening on
mobile side.
So we've added something called
Google Cloud Endpoints
that basically is targeting to
make it as simple as possible
from an Auth perspective,
connectivity perspective, and
so forth to coordinate
between server side
code and client code.
Now we have a really neat
thing called the Mobile
Backend Starter, which is on our
websites, which I really
encourage you to take
for a spin.
And it basically includes the
client library in the backend
started stuff to just hook
together your application with
App Engine, with our storage
systems, and coordinate it
with the Google Cloud Messaging
from the Android
universe and make this stuff
have as little pain as
possible to get this
up and running.
So the general areas of 2013 for
App Engine is sort of to
move applications to the
solutions we've been rolling
out earlier this year to improve
customer experience.
We have a tier of support now.
In particular, we have a tier
called Gold Support and up,
and gold is still $400 per
month, I think, and up.
And if you do anything that's
important to you on App Engine
or Cloud, please go gold or
higher for God sakes.
I keep getting emails, support
hasn't been responsive.
And I'm like, what's
your support level?
Oh, you haven't signed up
for a support contract.
Adding sensibility to it and
improving accessibility-- a
lot of the things that we're
doing now is really addressing
a lot of the limitations and
constraints and challenges
that our developers encountered
over the last year
with App Engine and sort of
fundamentally moved the
goalposts on the developer
experience.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]